hey I left endicott here and I just want
to say thank you
the channel reached a hundred
subscribers this week and I just want to
say thank you for all my subscribers and
viewers I plan on continuing this
project and making weekly videos on the
tidy Tuesday data set however this week
this tie you Tuesday data set is on
cocktails but when I was reading that
comments I noticed a lot of you guys
wanted to do wanted me to make more
videos on tidy models so I figured it'd
be kind of an interesting thing to do
some computer vision with the tidy
models package and with computer vision
kind of like the hello world of of a
computer vision is the amnesty data set
or database we're essentially it's
handwritten data set handwritten digits
where you're trying to classify each
image and the number that it was written
we're also going to go over some
clustering which is a good way to
basically visualize um high dimensional
data so when we open up markdown we're
gonna actually load in the tidy verse
Kerris and tidy models okay
so what's cool about Kerris is carrots
actually comes with the m nist data set
so that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna first to load it in and we'll call
us the m nist data and then in the M
nest data it actually comes with a
training test set and within the train
and test sets have an x and y values so
the x is actually the kind of the the
pixels of the actual image where it's
actually a black and white image so
these will represent I believe I guess a
white
yeah like white and the numbers walks
you represent um black or the actual
digit so we're gonna do this we're gonna
say the we're going to bring in the
gauge set and call it image
data and if we look at our image data
its dimensions we see that we have
60,000 images and these images are 28 by
28 so 28 by 28 pixels which is about
let's see here 784 total I guess what we
would say features however if we look at
this it is a 28 by 28 matrix matrix but
it's all twisted matrices okay so well
we all stop the load-in is the actual
image labels so that's what we're gonna
do we're gonna call em nist
data train and then why okay so when
we're actually gonna be visualizing
these image datasets these images or to
do the actual cost string when you
actually convert this and to a kind of a
digestible format for most of our
processing okay so originally this is
actually for i guess or the neural
network however what we're gonna do is
we're gonna use the we're gonna use t
Snee or t what is called t distributed
stochastic neighbor embeddings which is
a clustering algorithm so to do that
we're actually have to reformat this
data so to reformat the data um caris
actually comes with a pretty cool thing
where it's we just called the it where
is it oops
where is it arrey arrey arrey reshape so
with array reshaped
array reshape we give it a X or data so
we'll say image data and we also give it
a dimension and for our dimension we
want to keep the actual um the the
amount of samples so in this case it
will go back here and get image data and
say dim we still want to keep the 60,000
um datasets or images however we want to
convert these matrices into basically a
list of columns right so if we do that
we say 28 by 28
I'll convert basically these square
matrices into long rows which is what we
want so we're going to put this in
oops image image data and we look at the
dimensions now we have 60,000 we still
have the 60,000 images however this I
guess square or two-dimensional feature
set is now converted to like a tabular
form okay and that's that's basically
what we want okay so when doing T Snee
we actually look at the the I guess the
creator of on the T sneak algorithm
it's called T distributed stochastic
neighbor embeddings and a josh Starner
actually has a real good video that kind
of explains it but it's actually a
pretty um simple algorithm it
essentially just kind of maps these
dimensions into a lower dimension and
starts and basically duh implements the
similarity by using the t-distribution
by using each points relative distance
so i know i'm not really great at
explaining that but josh Stone has a
real good video on it and one of the
main reasons why we should use T sneak
over things like pca is because
tea-stained is actually a nonlinear
clustering algorithm and it has many
implementations in different languages
so it's a pretty fast and nonlinear
clustering algorithm which is really
useful for visualizing a lot of high
dimensional data okay so when we're
doing this um since we have 60,000
images I'm actually going to take only
the first 10,000 okay so we're gonna do
that we're going to take the first
10,000
image labels Wow oh I told him Anjali
was wrong that's why okay just like
labels I said okay image labels and then
we'll do the first ten one two three ten
thousand okay so now we have the first
ten thousand images we're actually gonna
load in the MT sneak package which is
called artiste name and if we look at
the artiste me package right it doesn't
have actually a lot of functions I think
it only comes with two function two
functions so it's a pretty
straightforward package but the main
thing we're really gonna use is then
normalize excuse me the normalized input
function and this essentially centers
and scales our data if we actually look
at our image data um the image data it's
here max can we do that the image data
has a max value of twelve fifty five and
min value of zero and that's just kind
of like the I guess I think like the
colors or whatever are in that type of
scale so we need to normalize the input
so we just don't want the input and
that'll see and that makes AC centers it
scales it so you now you see how there's
no torn 55s or anything like that it's
all centered I guess like in the
negative one in one range okay and we're
still gonna put this into our we're
gonna press on that to our image data
and then what we're simply gonna do is
gonna create a TC object in this case
I'm gonna call it a TC need data frame
and we'll use the artiste need function
give it the image data and the artis
sneak artisti has a decent model
parameters so we go here and what's your
zoom we can see that there's perplexity
theta PC a partial
max iterations for both all the stuff
however the main thing that we really
want to deal with is I guess perplexity
right and what's kind of cool about this
is the creator of Artie's knee kind of
has some nice like high-level
information explaining around it so what
he's saying basically is loosely
speaking one could say that a larger
denser dataset requires a larger
perplexity typical values for the
perplexity range between 5 and 50 and
then he also says perplexity can
basically be compared to compared to the
numbers of nearest neighbors as k okay
so what we can do is I'm actually to set
the set that perplexity to about 25 I
think that's a good number because
that's basically in between 5 and 50 and
we really don't know how was your tune
it additionally like if we really wanted
to get into Artie's knee or just um T's
knee clustering we could go and do some
type of grid search for the perplexity
additionally we can specify the
dimensions so by default it returns to
UM two columns however well I'm gonna do
is brush um ask for three columns okay
so now we're running the TC algorithm on
the 10000 image data if you might if you
notice on the image data doesn't have
the actual labels so the labels are
independent of the actual T's new
algorithm okay we're gonna create a new
chunk and then I thought it'd be
interesting when we're after we were
finished running the T sneak algorithm
is to visualize a 3d 3-dimensional
embeddings and to do that we're actually
going to load in the though the poly
package which contains a lot of cool 3d
charting things so if we will get 3d
plot lis plots in R we can see that um
it comes with a lot of cool little basic
3d scatter plots all right let's see
fill it up
and you see this is just made in our and
saved as like an HTML widget well you
can kind of visualize the 3d axes and a
pretty intuitive manner and it's kind of
fun to kind of drag around um you can
like see the call-outs you can I think
you can zoom in to yeah you can you can
zoom in and stuff like that so it's a
pretty cool on package I kind of want to
start using poly for my dashboards but
I've ever gotten into it too much okay
so it's still running per poxy of 25
okay um what else can we ok yeah there's
also a lot of things that you can
specify um you can do like PCA - um with
two T's neat and you can also look runty
sneak over and over on itself so you can
do time kind of like this feedback and
area of process on it okay so now that
we have the TC data frame we can kind of
look at it and it's actually not add a
frame it's comical twists over these
random things but if we look at the I
guess why you can see that we have our
three embeddings that we wanted that
represents on the image data set which
is actually kind of nice because we
transformed 784 features into three
features that can really summarize our
entire dataset okay so once we load in
potli well we're gonna create is kind of
a a plot ly DF and what we're gonna do
is we're gonna create as table and we'll
do dat he's the ADF Y and I won't say uh
let's see here we'll do a C buying was
it the image data yeah and do that
so now that if we look at our plot we of
what Watley DF here
Oh what's it what's it doing right now
okay there we go we have oh oh not our
image data we need our image labels
there you go so now we have our image
labels let's see here
okay so to actually create the UM the
plot we use the plot we function we give
it our hot Loyd data we specify our X
which is x equals to V 1 or Y which is
equal to V 2 and our Z which is equal to
V 3 and we have to use these Tilda's I
guess it's like a kind of unique to poly
now I'm sure why then we can also
specify our color labels so in this case
we'll do a Mincha labels and now I think
about it we probably need to do some
processing for example our image labels
are integers so we need to mutate that
so we're just gonna call it labels I
think it's either type so labels equals
emoji labels as that factor let's see if
that works okay so we have that right
and you're gonna get running this error
with I guess markdown what we're also
gonna have to do is add the markers
right and it's still not gonna say it's
not supported but we're gonna put this
into our us our our plot object so we'll
say plot Lee I'll say what plot what is
it 3d ok so now that we have our plot
Lee object what we're gonna do is we're
gonna just save using the HTML widget
and say save widget plot 3d and the file
will equal to TC plot HTML okay so it's
gonna save that I'm gonna open up my tie
a Tuesday oh don't find our T's new pot
right here
now we can actually visualize our tea
Snee pot okay ooh maybe I have to make
this I'm actually in changes because
it's not actually putting this as a
factor it's more as a continuous
variable so let me change that and then
UK labels equals a thought factor labels
okay let's see if I changed it okay well
I guess I did well well we can kind of
look at something and see that okay
there appears to be specific clusters
right and actually makes pretty makes a
decent mountain sense
um there's defined clusters and these
clusters are representing the actual
numbers right and we can see with the
color labels so we can see that it's
actually working pretty well the tea's
new algorithm actually found out some
relevant clusters that actually
clustered each image to its respective
Henri and label he's pretty great okay
so once we have that um well I thinking
about doing is we could probably put
this into our tidy models framework so
since we have our tidy models package
already loaded into and we have our pot
Li DF right
I'm actually not oh oh that's why I just
said all I say there we go sorry about
that
i toi forgot that i was renaming it okay
we're gonna actually look at this again
just for more clarification there we go
so now you can definitely see how there
are set on clusters that are respective
to their own labels and TC didn't even
look at the actual labels right so there
leakage it just found the clustering of
the actual black black pen writing and
decided that there were very similar
things and intuitively that makes sense
and that's how we kind of look at um
digits we say oh well this line looks
like a1 yolks
it looks similar to that past ones I've
seen so we're gonna put them together um
and obviously there's probably some
problems right with say like what's the
difference between a 7 and a 1 right
sometimes people make the 7 the top of
the 7 is really short you can mistake
that for being a 1 so some it's not
perfect but it did cost right pretty
well you can see how some of the
clusters do contain um the wrong points
and that's fine we could actually tweak
it and do that but we can see soon to
finna ball definable clusters cool so we
have our pot we DF and I'm actually
going to create I'm gonna say select -
image labels boom and I'm gonna call us
our model data okay so now let's start
actually doing the modeling if you think
about it we actually created some
feature engineering engineering as a
common thing um to do some type of
feature reduction before you start
modeling if we actually look at the
Amnesty wiki you can see that there's a
nonlinear classifier that they use and
they just used 40 principle components
okay to achieve like a 3 / 3 points:3
percent error rate in this case we're
actually only gonna use three components
from our TCE clustering art artisti
embeddings okay so we're using 3
features to really predict I guess 10
labels which is kind of a big deal
that's that's actually very impressive
right so that's what we were gonna do so
we have our model data we should
probably make our tidy split so uh was
it initial split model data and we'll
say crop equals 0.8 okay and then okay
okay
our tidy train training tidy split tidy
test testing testing
tidy slip okay so we're gonna say create
model data and and partition in to train
and test cool
hmm perform tease me vish visualize the
embeddings using
slightly cool and then we'll say
reformat image images to tab your format
let's place what we did okay cool
so we created our training test sets um
now we need to make a tidy recipe and we
notice with our model data the the
ranges are not centered right there in
there in different ranges yeah they're
probably the same ranges because they're
using the same embeddings but they're
not between 0 and 1 or not in the
negative 1 and 1 range which a lot of
models prefer so in this case we're
gonna actually create a recipe so create
create a recipe or pre-processing tidy
wreck start out your recipe recipe and
we're going to be predicting our wizard
our labels again yeah labels data equals
our tidy train ok and what we're gonna
do is we're gonna step Center all
predictors step scale all predictors ok
cool so
um I was reading more about the tidy
recipes and basically you're always
gonna do a tidy prep right so we're
gonna say prep Oh
tidy rack view it what's it doing you
know it's doing sarin scale for those
values so I've been doing the tidy juice
right where it's like chai tea teddy
juice juice tidy wreck up tidy chai tea
prep and what you really does is it just
creates the it creates like the was it
the the training the pre-processed
training testa training set if you
wanted to do apply it to say like
another data set that you just left out
you actually use the bake function right
so we bake and you'd be was it tidy prep
and then you could do like tidy tests
right anyway to apply your recipe to the
that whatever data so I wanted to do it
all see you tidy train I don't do the
same thing so if you really want to
apply the recipe you just do bake and
you give it the tidy prepped recipe and
a data set okay
realistically we don't really need to
use these things because I'm just kind
of doing the Monica procedure but if you
want to do a pipeline stuff like that
these will probably very necessary cool
so I'm just gonna go to the next chunk
okay so we're gonna say training models
and for for this tidy Tuesday I thought
it'd be interesting to kind of do I
guess every time I do a tidy models to
basically use a different model and with
computer vision one of the models that
they use that it's actually a really
intuitive model is a cane yours Nagar
QK nearest neighbor algorithm so we look
at the tidy models unpackage let's see
okay - all so um we're gonna use the K
nearest neighbor package arcadia nearest
neighbor neighbor model and they can
model is actually pretty intuitive um if
they see is doing kind of what the t
Snee algorithm is doing where it's
basically assigns um where you basically
set the amount on neighbors and
neighbors racy represent the amount of
points you wouldn't use and the basic
intuition between cannon is saying that
you're basically asking a certain amount
of neighbors how they would classify
themselves and then you take the
majority of vote so if you ask say ten
neighbors right if you go up to ten
neighbors and say where are we like what
state are we in and they say oh well
nine out of ten of them say we're in the
state of Iowa then you would classify
that area as Iowa and in this case this
area can be basically used as a sample
in the data set okay so we're going to
create our first workflow so workflow
and recipe I'm going to be tidy wreck
okay so we have a recipe and then we're
going to do the tidy KNN and we use a
nearest neighbor
what is it the nearest neighbor uses
neighbors equals tune set mode set mode
classification set engine K K and K
nearest neighbors one thing that we
should note is that this this problem is
actually kind of a harder problem
because there are actually ten labels
which doesn't make which makes it into a
multi-class classification a problem so
a lot of times with multi-class
classification problems usually the
class balance is not correct and it's
highly imbalanced data or say like three
out of the ten classes are very frequent
and the remaining seven out of ten
are very rare however in this case if we
actually look at our say tied a train
and count the labels we can see that we
pretty much have an equal distribution
of these labels which makes the emne
store the handwritten data set a very
great toy data set to work with when
you're creating models okay
so first we're gonna say establish
create a KNN model we should also always
create a baseline model we're gonna say
create a create a oops baseline model
okay and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna use the logistic regression model
and this is a multinomial regression I
actually tried the logistic regression
when I'm trying out multi-class
classification I kept on running here an
error so I think you might have to use a
multinomial regression to do multi-class
classification that are analogous to a
logistic model so we're gonna do we're
gonna tune the penalty we're gonna also
tune our mixture he has all these linear
regression or GLM style models come with
a penalty in a mixture I guess um we're
gonna set the mode to classification set
engine to GL m-net okay so we have our
baseline Encana and model now we're
gonna do is we're gonna create a grid
search create a create a grid for the
models so we're set this for the can
grid so we'll call this a KN grid grid
regul regular give it the parameters
which are neighbors and we'll give it
the length or the amount of comic wolves
or the amount of your not linked levels
and this like the amount of primers we
want to try in this case let's just try
10
it will look at our can and grid let me
see this thing 1 1 through 10 honestly
I'm not really a fan of this I actually
might I would like to actually change it
but it doesn't seem realistic for how
many features we have right now ok so
again what we're gonna do now is we're
gonna create a was it the just baseline
grid and this is the logistic so
logistic who's let just dick bread bread
or a your penalty penalty mixture levels
equals 10 okay so we have our grid and
now what we're gonna do is we're gonna
start training up these models first we
must make air we're gonna do this a
carrot way so we're gonna basically tune
we're gonna give it our grid of
parameters and tune a model but we're
actually going to use capables
cross-validation to actually do the main
evaluation for what are the best
parameters or we're gonna basically use
cables to do the parameter search so
we're gonna create a capable to object
using the k-fold I mean the v-fold cv
give it our training set that will train
our miles on and we'll say ten folds
okay so create k folds object or dataset
yeah and then I'm gonna start tuning our
models so we're gonna train our our
baseline first so we'll say logistic
thun thun grid give it our workflow and
add the model to it which is the tidy
logistic then we're gonna give it our
resamples which our resembles is a tidy
k folds and then we're gonna give it our
grid which our grid is the logistic grid
additionally we're going to create the
KNN tune give it the same
dang basically to in grid add monell
tidy cannon oops
give it the same resamples Teddy K folds
give it our grid Canaan grid and we're
gonna run this I'm sure this this will
take a while because we're having we're
training basically like on 8000 samples
so I'll get back to you guys once it
finishes okay so the models finished
tuning and now we're gonna actually
analyze the the training process and see
what was actually the best tuning
parameters so first when I grab the
eulogistic tune so collect metrics and
we look at this we can see that there is
um it brings accuracy and ROC so I'm
pretty sure ROC na you see is not really
useful for multi-class classification
metrics there I believe there are all
multi-class ROC metric however I think
with tidy models they only give you the
binary so we're actually gonna filter it
out
so filter dot metric is equal to
accuracy okay and then we're gonna do
select was it penalty mixture and then
mean and we'll just you plot it out so
Judy pot yes x equals penalty y equals
mixture color equals mean plus Q okay so
that's not a great um way to visualize
it so we're gonna do a different way
pivot longer- mean there you go and we
can now we can do a better to G pot so
i'm jim and their facet wrap whoa oh
that's what and I'm just uh I'm losing
it okay
value and then mean there we go so we
can see how the mixture kind of kind of
has this weird see-sawing effect all
right and then we can all see our
penalty ah has definitely as a penalty
increases our our actual mean
performance or Meenaxi
goes down cool okay so now let's look at
our k9 metrics so collect metrics just
should be let me see what it's called
again okay because we only have one
parameter that we're tuning we're gonna
just filter out metric Eagles accuracy
and then ggplot the neighbors so AS x
equals neighbors michaels mean genome
line okay and we can see that I guess
our optimum their neighbor is five
neighbors additionally we can see that
our K nearest neighbor is house seems to
have much better performance than our
linear regression or logistic regression
model however KNN is definitely prone to
overfitting and honestly the amount of
neighbors were used is definitely
suspect where the less amount of
neighbors the more likely it is to over
fit or the more sensitive to outliers
okay and that's kind of and that's kind
of makes sense right if you ask only one
person for their for the answer of like
some problem
it's highly sensitive to that person so
that person could be right or we could
be wrong
we've asked say a hundred people
and take the average of that of it
you're probably more likely to be right
okay cool so we're gonna create the tidy
best I will say tidy we're gonna create
the new models let's say create new
models with final parameters okay so
tidy look just stick a finalized model
tidy logistic and then logistic tune
select best and this time we're going
for accuracy and we get that and then
we'll do the tidy cannon finalized model
tidy cannon sorry and then with you
cannon tune select best accuracy okay so
we now have our part to final models
right yeah
boom and then we have oh whoa 20 of Tidy
cannon so now we have our two optimal
models cool five penalty of I don't know
and point six okay so now we're going to
create our final metrics so use our
workflow add our model in this case
we're going to use a tidy logistic last
fit tie a split and will then collect
our metrics okay and we can see our
accuracy is 92% very good for our model
for our logistic regression model now
let's evaluate our other one so tidy KN
last fit tidy split and then collect
metrics
okay and we can see something our Kanan
model um definitely does a little bit
better than our tidy logistic regression
model however if you think about it
there's a three percent difference and
this three percent difference is
substantial in some use cases right
however we got to also acknowledge that
I do gistic regression formula it's
gonna be a little bit faster right you
could put this in as probably a sequel
database and run it assuming that you
have the actual T sneak embeddings with
a KN you kinda have to save the actual
data set because it has to reference it
right so as to say okay since we're
using five neighbors we're gonna get a
new data set new data point or new data
sample or new image and compare it to
five other images that are similar to it
and you can see how that can add up
especially when you're putting something
on this scale so I think that's about it
um this is a pretty quick video honestly
um but we can kind of see how tidy
models is definitely getting more
intuitive for me and I think these
videos kind of are solidifying this
specific process that I you do when
creating these models I'll see you guys
next week and yeah tae-yong